Это этап номер три, профиль и комменты.
Так что мы делаем здесь, пытайся добавить твой профиль с именем «Аватар» и «Интерфейс».
Да, интерфейс.
Нет, нет, нет, нет, нет, нет, нет, нет, нет.
Это будет просто фотография.
Я думаю что аватар works.
Если I change my name, I'll just change, I'll just add that.
Seems to update very quickly in real-time.
«Translation language, same as interface language».
О, I can change that.
If I toggle it.
О, окей.
So this is so I can have the, like, display language be one.
And then I can set a default translation language if I'm in a meeting.
Okay, I've just set it to Russian.
Okay, meeting preferences.
Show pre-join dialogue.
Setup screen before joining a meeting.
All the buttons seem to work.
I think I'm really not.
I mean, obviously I can't see what this is doing until I join a meeting.
But.
Okay, then let's go on to the themes.
Okay, theme colors.
I believe I'm on the light theme right now.
What happens if I click reset?
Okay, it doesn't change.
How do I change to the dark theme?
I can change the colors on it.
Um.
So let's see if I change.
Oh, I can see it's changing the color of the applications.
And then.
There's the blue.
Yeah, it's changing the color of the buttons.
Okay.
That all seems to be working well.
Um, I'm sure.
How.
I can't seem to see where I would change to.
The dark thing.
I don't.
I think maybe that's something.
To do in.
Your actual browser.
So.
Perhaps.
The next step of changing language.
Or.
Oh, no.
In the application preferences.
When I'm.
Ah.
You can change the colors.
There's light theme and dark theme.
Ah, yeah.
I see.
Can't change.
Uh.
I don't think you can change it in.
The website.
I think you have to change maybe.
Your preference in the browser.
The browser.
Okay.
I have no idea.
Anyway.
What's the.
Next step.
Okay.
I have no idea.
Anyway.
What's the.
Next step.
Okay.
I have no idea.
Anyway.
What's the.
Next step.
Okay.
I have no idea.
Anyway.
What's the.
Next step.
Okay.
I have no idea.
Anyway.
What's the.
Next step.
Okay.
I have no idea.
Anyway.
What's the.
Next step.
Okay.
I have no idea.
Anyway.
Next step.
Is.
Uh.
Find.
A button.
To change your language.
Or page.
Okay.
Try to change it.
Change it.
To any of the language.
Or homepage.
Maybe.
If you are.
Trying to find.
Uh.
The button.
To change.
Or page.
Maybe.
If you are.
Trying to.
Find.
Uh.
The button.
To change.
Uh.
The button.
To change.
Uh.
The language.
To comment everything.
Yep.
Okay.
So.
I'm just gonna go.
Through each of the things.
One by one.
I don't see.
Any.
Anything.
To change.
The.
Language of the page.
In meetings.
If I go into channels.
I have no chats.
Or anything open.
Right now.
But.
I still don't see.
Any sort of.
Button.
To change.
The language.
Of the page.
Go into settings.
This is where.
I presume.
It would be.
There is.
Something to change.
The translation language.
However.
The.
This doesn't change.
The language of the page.
I think.
This just.
Sets.
A default.
For what you want.
The translated language.
To be.
In meetings.
So.
Actually.
I would imagine.
That.
Would.
Meeting preferences.
Instead of user.
Uh.
Show pre-joined dialogue.
Yeah.
So.
Settings.
Also.
Doesn't show.
Any way to change.
The language of the.
Website.
Okay.
Integration.
Calendar integration.
Yeah.
I'm.
Still not.
Finding.
Anywhere.
To find.
Where.
I would.
Change.
Language.
Of the website.
Billing.
Still not there.
I gotta.
Help.
Because.
I'm.
Struggling.
With.
Finding.
It.
How.
Do.
I.
Change.
The.
Language.
Of.
The.
Website.
Us.
Strings.
Is.
Selected.
From.
The.
Language.
Switcher.
Located.
In.
The.
App.
Header.
Where.
Is.
That.
Okay.
I.
Found.
The.
Thing.
For.
Toggle.
Theme.
Okay.
Silly.
Me.
Um.
Where.
Is.
The.
App.
Head.
Up.
The.
Documentation.
States.
The.
Language.
Switcher.
Which.
Controls.
The.
Website.
Okay.
So.
It.
Doesn't.
Know.
Where.
I.
Can.
Change.
This.
I.
Presume.
It.
Means.
In.
The.
Link.
Yeah.
I.
Mean.
Don't.
See.
I.
Know.
There.
Was.
An.
Option.
To.
Change.
Language.
On.
The.
Main.
Website.
But.
On.
This.
Like.
The.
On.
User.
Website.
I.
Really.
Don't.
See.
Anything.
Yeah.
That's.
A.
Right.
Okay.
I.
Also.
Can't.
Find.
Any.
Button.
To.
Change.
Language.
On.
Application.
Page.
So.
Let's.
Go.
To.
The.
Next.
Step.
Okay.
I.
See.
You.
Can.
Create.
Join.
And.
Schedule.
Meetings.
Create.
Join.
And.
Schedule.
Meetings.
I'm.
Not.
Sure.
Perhaps.
New.
Channel.
Maybe.
Add.
Contacts.
I.
Don't.
Have.
Any.
Contacts.
Try.
To.
Create.
Chat.
Any.
Channels.
And.
Send.
Me.
Invite.
Link.
Okay.
I.
Can't.
Create.
A.
Channel.
Without.
Contacts.
And.
I.
Can.
Send.
You.
A.
Link.
I.
Send.
To.
You.
My.
Mail.
Okay.
So.
I.
Have.
A.
Meeting.
And.
Then.
I.
Email.
You.
The.
Meeting.
Link.
Субтитры сделал DimaTorzok
I was gonna say that
So I can choose
Meek
It's actually
It's actually works
Yep
I think I can see
This
On the speaker test
My music
Became very loud
And now I press the button to join the meeting
I'm waiting for approval from Oscar's side
Also joining the meeting
It's loading
Okay
Waiting for approval
See a pop-up in the top left
Evgeny Karalev
Wants to join
Deny or admit
I admit
I think he's joined
I think he's joined the meeting
Okay
I'll try to open the invite link again
Oscar, are you left the meeting?
Yeah, yeah
I left
Alright
I use the same link to join the meeting
I still can't do that
I'm passing all the presets
with the microphone and camera
I'm joining the meeting
I joined it without permission
Are you still here?
Yeah, I just
I just
I can't pass all the
All right
On your meeting page
I think you have
a list of a meeting
our recent one
Try to delete this link
And now try to open the same link
for a meeting
Click delete for everyone
Delete it
This meeting escaped from my site
on my meeting
on my meeting page
So I don't see any meetings
with the Oscar
So now I use the same link to join the meeting
Now I see camera set up and microphone
I also need to join the meeting
And now I'm waiting for approval
But the meeting is already deleted
And also no one can let me in
Because the meeting does not exist
All right
Let's create another meeting
For the last one
I'll create a meeting
I'll send a link to Oscar
Yep
I'm enjoying the meeting
By myself
Let's open it now
I'm in a meeting right now
Okay
I'm going on the link
That I've been sent
Loading up
It's a very similar
Process to before
Start with camera set up
The same calming music
In the background
Everything going the exact same
Microphone set up working
Speaker test
I can hear the music
Okay all set
Language Russian
Join me
I'm just waiting for approval
Seeing pop from Oscar
Marae wants to drown
I can deny
I'll admit
I'm still in now
Accepted
Pop saying pop up
The transcript is being recorded
The next part is change role
I will give role admin to Oscar
But I can't find him anymore
Let's check in the meeting
Settings
I'm not going to grant
Admin role to Oscar
So let's pause the step
Let's leave the meeting
And we'll finish this step
Okay
Another stop recording
I thought it was 4
There is a
There's a 4
Yes it was number 4
There's autostops
3 and 4
Was that 3 and 4?
No it was a 3
Sorry
And I need to rename it
I think that was 3 and 4
Yeah
Next one
Try to
Name your video part
Like Oscar
Part
Okay
Yep